[Music]
here are the 10 weirdest and the most
unique movie alien monster designs the
ones that are not humanoid
nor do they look like any typical grey
alien or space dragons or any of the
regular looking alien monsters
so subscribe if you haven't already and
now let's get on with this monster
content number one the heptapods from
arrival
these are advanced peaceful space-faring
aliens that have the strange ability to
see time in a different way than us
humans they have jointed arthropod-like
limbs each ending in a point that can
split open into seven pointed star fish
like hands
they have a dull gray fleshy looking
skin with a smooth texture
and they seem to have no visible eyes or
mouths
the seven appendages only form
a small lower portion of the heptapod's
body with a large upper section that
resembles a long diamond shaped body of
a squid and a head-like object at the
top
seen in silhouette the upper body of the
heteropod kind of resembles a vaguely
humanoid figure
they appear to be huge at 9 to 10 meters
or 30 to 33 feet tall
number two the xenomorphs from the alien
franchise
these are undoubtedly the most famous of
all the alien monsters one of the
deadliest of all known alien species in
practically all multiverses of movies
these creatures require a host organism
in order to reproduce the appearance of
the xenomorph can vary depending on the
hose in which the embryo is implanted
but essentially they have an elongated
head with no eyes or visible ears and a
mouth full of fangs with an inner
secondary mouth that juts out while
attacking they have two volumes and two
hind limbs and the body is biomechanical
and looks with dull ended spires or
dorsal spines that grow from their backs
they also have a long prehensile tail
with a bladed tip at the end
they are dark colored and most are 2.1
to 2.7 meters or 7 to 9 feet tall but
some like the queen can be up to 6 to 9
meters or 20 to 30 feet tall
number three the goliath monster from
the 2010 movie monsters
while the octopus looking aliens from
that same movie are weird looking they
still do look a lot like the cephalopods
of the world's oceans you know the
octopus and squids
but there are another type of alien in
this movie these goliath monsters are
similar to the octopus monsters but
possess a long cluster stalk resembling
a neck with numerous other tentacles
growing out of it
any octopus monster can turn into a
goliath monster given time to grow these
forms seem to possess light pulsating
organs and whether it's for
communication is still up to debate
these are giants that can grow up to
around 86 meters or 280 feet in height
number 4 the mega kaiju from pacific rim
uprising
kaijus are gigantic alien monsters from
another dimension called the antiverse
colossal in size averaging hundreds of
feet in height and thousands of tons in
weight
because of their body mass two brains
are needed to control the kaiju's body
functions these masses vary greatly in
shape and size even amongst themselves
but here we will discuss the design of
the mega kaiju it is a fusion of three
other kaijus it is hexapetal meaning it
has six limbs each with sharp claws and
talons its body is heavily armoured with
sharp and exoskeletal plates and spines
on its back and a very long tail with
sharp spikes at the tip it has ten eyes
two sharp tusks and a mouth full of
sharp teeth it is over 419 feet tall and
weighs
over 7800 tons
number five the queen arachnid from
starship troopers the queen buck is one
of the leadership cars of the box and
plays a vital role within the arky of
the arachnids although queens can lay
eggs to produce more arachnids that
isn't her only purpose
in terms of appearance the creature
shares some of the elements seen amongst
the certain types of bugs such as the
warrior bug but with a larger large beak
type mouth with a crown head it has two
large limbs that can be used to grasp
the ground along with the two smaller
ones to hold prey as well as six smaller
legs to move across the environment its
body is encased in a very hot
exoskeleton that has a lot of segments
it has nine eyes and a mouth that is
truly hard to describe
number six legion from the gemara movies
the legion are a colony of
extraterrestrial species of
silicon-based organisms the most unique
form of theirs is the queen legion
on her abdominal region she spots
multiple egg cases which houses
symbiotic legion soldiers
its entire body the queen legion is
encased in a silicon shell and the
entire thing is multi-segmented it has
multiple legs and sickle-shaped limbs
behind them in front there are two
tunneling arms as well as 10 claws
that form kind of like a crown around
the head
that itself has a huge horn on the front
on the top of the torso is yet another
gigantic sickle shaped outgrowth like
horn
its eyes are blue has a mouth that can
shoot lasers and it is 140 meters or
feet in height
number seven calvin from the movie life
this alien right here is a very peculiar
organism that was discovered on mars and
was cultured in a lab aboard the
spaceship that brought a manned research
team to the red planet calvin is first
discovered as a sample of a dominant
organic tissue similar to that of an
amoeba
when provided with simple nutrients and
water it begins to grow into a
multicellular form in this form it looks
like a fungal mold that can move about
it then grows into another form that
looks kind of like a flower with leafy
petals that have veins and neurons
visible from the outside
kelvin is an apex predator of mars and
is theorized that this species is the
one that wiped out all life on that
planet
its final form was gigantic it looked
like a flower like cephalopod with
multiple limbs and leafy tentacles as
well as a mouth that has six lips that
open up in different directions
kelvin is hella weird
number eight symbiotes from the venom
movies
these are extraterrestrials created from
the living abyss by a dark god called
null
symbiotes were first seen in movies a
well in the third spider-man movie from
2007 that was their debut and now are
famous in their own right with the venom
movies bringing them up from obscurity
symbiotes are dark amorphous symbiotic
and parasitic beings that appear simply
as a dark blob or mole that can stretch
and make their way around with
surprising agility but when they attach
themselves to a hose they would merge
and transform the hose into a monstrous
being with the ability to create
tendrils tentacles blades shields and
whatnot from their constituent element
or matter
they are similar to the blob in design
but are more unique in a sense that they
can create shapes and alter their host's
powers
number nine the shimmer from the movie
annihilation lastly we have a strange
alien that was seen in the end of the
movie annihilation
and it is called the shimmer it is an
amorphous being of unknown origin that
crashed landed on earth and began to
transform the surrounding area and
create what is known as area x
which itself has been called the shimmer
although the symbiotes were also
amorphous
uh like this one but this one is kind of
different as it looks to be a bit
gaseous and energy based it closely
resembles an artificially created
material called the mandible whose
structure is ever-changing as well as
having near infinite protrusions as well
as sublimations the shimmer then
transforms into a humanoid being after
absorbing a bloody tear from one of the
characters of the movie
anyway with that we come to the end of
this video of the 9 unique and weirdest
movie alien monsters
so subscribe if you haven't
ring that bell button for regular
updates and like our video for support
so
till the next one take care fam